the hardest sleep the most importantly
but some
precarious to to eukaryotes
eukaryotically what's the second if
we're ranking what's what's the what's
uh you gave a lot of emphasis on
photosynthesis yeah and that would be my
second one I think but it's it's not so
much I mean photosynthesis is part of
the problem it's a difficult thing to do
uh again we know it happened once we
don't know why it happened once
um but
the fact that
it was kind of Taken on board completely
by plants and algae and so on as
chloroplasts
and did very well in completely
different environments and then on land
and whatever else seems to suggest that
there's no there's no problem with
exploring whether you know you could
have a separate origin that explored
this whole domain over there that the
bacteria had never gone into
um so that kind of says that the reason
that it only happened once is probably
because it's difficult because the
wiring is difficult yeah um but then it
happened at least 2.2 billion years ago
right before the goe maybe as long as
three billion years ago when there are
some people say there are whiffs of
oxygen there's just kind of traces in
the fossil in the in the in the
geochemical record that say maybe
there's a bit of oxygen then that's
really disputed some people say it goes
all the way back forward within years
ago and and um that it was the common
ancestor of life on Earth was
photosynthetic so immediately you've got
you know groups of people who disagree
over a two billion year period of time
about when it started
um but what
let's take the latest date when it's
unequivocal that's 2.2 billion years ago
through to around about the time of the
Cambrian explosion when oxygen levels
definitely got close to Modern levels
uh which was around about 550 million
years ago so we've gone more than one
and a half billion years
where the Earth was in stasis
um nothing much changed it's known as
the boring billion in fact
um probably stuff was that was when
eukaryots arose somewhere in there but
it's uh
so this idea that the world is
constantly changing that we're
constantly evolving that we're moving up
some ramp it's a very human idea but in
reality the the there are
um they're they're kind of
tipping points to a new stable
equilibrium where the cells that are
producing oxygen are precisely
counterbalanced by the cells that are
consuming that oxygen which is why it's
21 now and has been that way for
hundreds of millions of years we have a
very precise balance you go to a Tipping
Point and you don't know where the next
stable States going to be but it can be
a long way from here
um and so if we change the world with
global warming there will be a Tipping
Point this question is where and when
and what's the next stable state it may
be uninhabitable to us it'll be
habitable to life for sure
but there may be something like the
Permian Extinction where 95 of species
go extinct and there's a five to ten
million year Gap and then life recovers
but
without humans and the question
statistically well without humans but
statistically does that ultimately lead
to Greater complexity more interesting
life
well after the first appearance of
oxygen with the goe there was a Tipping
Point which led to a long-term stable
state that was equivalent to the black
seed today which is to say oxygenated at
the very surface and stagnant sterile
not sterile but um but but sulfurous
lower down
um and and that was stable certainly
around the Continental margins for more
than a billion years uh it was not a
state that led to progression in an
obvious way
um
yeah I mean it's interesting to think
about Evolution like what leads to
stable States
and uh how often are
evolutionary pressures
emerging from the environment
so maybe other planets are able to
create evolutionary pressures chemical
pressures whatever some kind of pressure
that say You're Screwed unless you get
your [ __ ] together in the next
like 10 000 years like a lot of pressure
uh it seems like Earth like the boring
building might be explained in two ways
one is super difficult to take any kind
of Next Step
and uh the second way could be explained
is there's no reason to take the next
step no I think there is no reason but
at the end of it there was a there was a
snowball Earth
um so there was a planetary catastrophe
on a huge scale where the the
ice was the the sea was frozen at the
equator
um
and that forced change in in one way or
another it's not long after that 100
million years perhaps after that so not
a short time but this is when we begin
to see animals there was a shift again
another Tipping Point that led to
catastrophic change that led to a a
takeoff then we don't really know why
but one of the reasons why that I
discuss in the book
um is about
sulfate being washed into the oceans
which sounds incredibly parochial
but the the issue is I mean that what
the data is showing we can we can track
roughly how oxygen was going into the
atmosphere from
um
from carbon Isotopes so there's two
there's two main isotopes of carbon that
we need to think about here one is
carbon 12 99 of carbon is carbon 12 and
then one percent of carbon is carbon 13
which is a stable isotope and then it's
carbon 14 which is a trivial radioactive
this turbulent amount
so carbon 13 is one percent and life and
enzymes generally you can think of
carbon atoms as
metal balls bouncing around Bing Bong
balls bouncing around carbon 12 moves a
little bit faster than carbon 13 because
it's lighter and it's more likely to
encounter an enzyme and so it's more
likely to be fixed into organic matter
and so organic matter is enriched and
this is just an observation it's
enriched in carbon 12 by a few percent
compared to carbon 13 relative to what
you would expect if it was just equal
and if you then bury organic matter
as coal or
oil or whatever it may be
then it's no longer oxidized so some
oxygen remains left over in in the
atmosphere and that's how oxygen
accumulates in the atmosphere and you
can work out historically how much
oxygen there must have been in the
atmosphere by how much carbon was being
buried and you think well how can we
possibly know how much carbon was being
buried and the answer is well if you're
burying carbon 12 or you're leaving
behind is more carbon 13 in the oceans
and that precipitous out in Limestone so
you can look at limestones over these
ages and work out what's the carbon 13
signal and that gives you a kind of a
feedback on what they what the oxygen
content right before the Cambrian
explosion there was what's called a
negative isotope anomaly Excursion which
is basically the carbon 13 goes down by
a massive amount and then back up again
10 million years later
and what that seems to be saying is the
amount of carbon 12 in the oceans
um was was disappearing
to say it was being oxidized
um and if it's being oxidized it's
consuming oxygen and that should so a
big carbon 13 signal says the ratio of
carbon-12 to carbon 13 is is really
going down which means there's there's
much more carbon 12 being taken out and
being oxidized sorry this is getting too
complex but well it's a good it's a good
way to estimate the amount of oxygen if
you calculate the amount of oxygen based
on the assumption that all this
carbon-12 that's being taken out is
being oxidized by oxygen the answer is
all the oxygen in the atmosphere gets
stripped out there is none left yeah
um and yet the rest of the geological
indicators say no there's oxygen in the
atmosphere
so it's a kind of a paradox and and the
only way to explain this Paradox just on
mass balance of how much stuff is in the
air how much stuff is in the oceans and
so on
um is to assume that it what oxygen was
not the oxygen it was sulfate sulfate
was being washed into the oceans
it's used as an electron acceptor by
sulfate reducing bacteria just as we use
oxygen as an electron acceptor so they
pass their electrons to sulfate instead
of oxygen
anteriorated yeah yeah so these are
these are these are bacteria so they're
oxidizing carbon organic carbon with
sulfate passing the electrons onto
sulfate that reacts with iron to form
iron pyrites or fool's gold sinks down
to the bottom gets buried out of the
system
um and this can account for the mass
balance so why does it matter it matters
because what it says is there was a
chance event
tectonically there was a lot of sulfate
sitting on land as a some kind of
mineral
uh so calcium sulfate minerals for
example are evaporitic
um and and because there happened to be
some continents some Continental
collisions mountain building the the
sulfate was pushed up the side of a
mountain and happened to get washed into
the ocean
yeah so I wonder how many happy
accidents like that are possible
statistically it's really hard you know
maybe you can rule that in statistically
but this is the course of life on Earth
without all that sulfate being raised up
the Cambrian explosion almost certainly
would not have happened
and then we wouldn't have had animals